in the meantime tonight the kyle
rittenhouse trial continued today in
wisconsin in a move that surprised
lawyers everywhere rittenhouse took the
stand in his own defense that is unusual
in criminal cases and it's especially
unusual in murder trials and the reason
it's simple the stakes are too high one
wrong answer in a cross-examination and
you could wind up spending life in
prison but this case was different by
the time he testified today kyle
rittenhouse had already won the case
at this point there was no remaining
doubt that kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense during the riots last
summer in kenosha every shot written
house fired was captured on videotape
and from multiple angles every single
witness who testified this week at the
trial confirmed exactly what happened
and here are the facts of it
a convicted child rapist called joseph
rosenbaum was released from a mental
hospital and then went directly to join
the mob that was burning downtown
kenosha
once he got to the riot rosenbaum saw
kyle rittenhouse and immediately
threatened to kill him
rosenbaum then chased rittenhouse and
tried to pull the gun from his hands
when he did that kyle rittenhouse shot
him
so joseph rosenbaum died as he had lived
trying to touch an unwilling minor
at this point rittenhouse ran to find
police ahmad then chased him down the
street howling for his death a rioter
jumped on written house and knocked him
to the ground another smashed him in the
face with a skateboard yet another drew
a loaded gun and pointed it in his face
kyle rittenhouse shot the second two men
one of them fatally
so those are the facts and there's no
way to interpret them except for what
they are the exercise of self-defense
kyle rittenhouse shot people so he would
not be killed
but if you take a step back from the
written house story you see something
else entirely you see violent insanity
completely out of control in the middle
of an american city
and the question is how did that happen
in our country and why did nobody stop
it and it wasn't just happening in
kenosha of course violent mobs at the
same moment overwhelmed new york and
minneapolis and portland and many other
cities they killed at least a dozen
people they caused hundreds of millions
of dollars in damage they burned
businesses they torched police stations
they bombed courthouses they invaded
suburban neighborhoods in the middle of
the night purely to intimidate people
because of their race
democrats applauded all of this as it
happened most republicans just ignored
it and of course the media lied about it
in kenosha the police barely even showed
up officers and armored cruisers sat and
watched as rioters torched a car lot
with more than 100 vehicles in it and
they did nothing to stop the chaos
the question then is how exactly are we
surprised when a 17 year old lifeguard
from illinois decides to step in
they hate it when you say that but it's
an entirely fair question when
legitimate authority refuses to do its
duty it's sworn duty others will fill
the vacuum
that is always true it's a physics
principle
but rather than acknowledge that obvious
truth and accept the responsibility they
bear the people who made these riots
possible in the first place decided
instead to crush kyle rittenhouse
joe biden publicly called him a white
supremacist something for which someday
we very much hope he is sued because
it's totally outrageous and false
members of congress called him a
domestic terrorist
today kyle rittenhouse spoke for himself
see what you think
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder
and mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and they were
so after a 10-minute break to compose
himself kyle rittenhouse returned to the
courtroom and proceeded to blow up the
prosecution's claim that he had racked
his rifle in a threatening manner it
turns out he didn't rack his rifle at
all and video proved that
and then rittenhouse explained why he
turned himself in to police after the
shootings
people were saying cranium him and get
him
kill him
people were screaming and i just was
trying to get to the police running down
sheridan road and you say i'm trying to
get to the police why were you trying to
get to the police because i didn't do
anything wrong i defended myself did you
feel as though there was safety where
the police were yes
so they didn't really have a response to
that since it's all on videotape it's
provably true so instead the lead
prosecutor in the case
in today's case
who is essentially an npr pledge drive
donor called thomas binger took a very
different attack he went on to imply
that kyle rittenhouse must be guilty
because he had exercised his
constitutional right to remain silent
after he was arrested watch
since august 25th 2020 this is the first
time
that you have told your story
since august 25th 2020 you've had the
benefit of watching countless videos
of your actions that night correct
you've also had the opportunity to
listen to the testimony of all
30 some witnesses that have testified in
this trial so far correct yes and after
all of that now you are telling us your
side of the story correct correct i am
making the point that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story
to what has already been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation
for you to talk about
the defendants silence
and that is and and you're right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but uh it better stop
understood
yeah this is day one of law school stuff
but just to be clear exercising your
constitutional rights is not an
indication that you are guilty it is a
sign that you are american it is your
birthright the government's own lawyer
does not understand that which you think
might get the attention of merrick
garland's justice department which after
all is in charge of justice in this
country
but no
maryland garland is not interested just
as he has ignored the thugs videotaping
jurors outside the courthouse the judge
in this case seems pretty well fed up
with all of it today he ruled that
prosecutors could not mention statements
about shoplifters that kyle rittenhouse
apparently made weeks before the
shootings prosecutors asked written
house about them anyway and once again
the judge was forced to shut down the
trial
i indicated a bias towards denial is
what i did held it open with a bias
towards denial why would you think that
that made it okay for you without any
advance notice to bring this matter
before the jury
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives
well i'll leave it at that
so i don't know what you're up
to you could watch televised trials for
the next 10 years and never hear a judge
talk like that that's how completely out
of control the prosecution in this case
is at this point it's not even clear
it's going to make it to a jury the
defense has asked the judge to dismiss
the case without the possibility of
retrial and the judge indicated he might
very well grant that request so again
what you are watching is willful
prosecutorial misconduct it's an
intentional perversion of justice and
the judge very well knows
that i had heard nothing in this trial
to change any of my rulings so why
testimony you're on pardon me that was
before that get brazen with me
uh
you knew very well
you
know very well that an attorney can't go
into these types of areas when the judge
has already ruled without asking outside
the presence of the jury to do so so
don't give me that
yeah don't give me that exactly good for
the judge
we should tell you we're so used to
evaluating everything through a partisan
lens that is worth knowing the judge in
this case that guy was appointed by a
democrat the point is however he still
believes in the constitution that's
always the point kyle rittenhouse should
be very grateful he's the judge in this
case
yesterday the prosecutor tried to bully
a freelance photographer called nathan
de bruin
in return that turned out to be a
mistake de bruyne read them out on live
television watch this
mr de bruin
you said there was a lot of tension in
the room when you met with me and mr
binger and ms beezy
yes
is it fair to say that you were very
nervous
yeah absolutely
and we did have you read over your
statement right correct and we asked if
you knew anything beyond that statement
correct we didn't ask you to change it
yes you did
yes you did
so pressuring a witness to change his
statement right that's exactly the kind
of justice that kyle rittenhouse has
received from the government so far no
one who's been paying attention is
surprised by any of this ghouls like joe
biden politicize this case day one
what's terrifying and very unnerving to
anyone who lives in this country is the
number of institutions that joined the
democratic party in trying to prevent
kyle rittenhouse from getting a fair
trial which again is your birthright as
an american here's one example in
virginia a police lieutenant called
william kelly was fired from his job
for daring to donate to kyle
rittenhouse's legal defense kelly was a
20-year veteran of the norfolk police
department he had three children and a
wife with cancer
for disagreeing with joe biden's view of
the rittenhouse case the department
dismissed him without a pension that
actually happened
in salt lake city a local news station
decided to terrorize a paramedic called
craig shepard his sin giving ten dollars
to written house's legal defense so
reporters called shepard's employer
another reporter showed up at shepard's
house with the camera crew and then
bragged about it quote
abc 4 news investigator jason nguyen
went to shepherd's home to get his side
of things but those inside the home
didn't want to talk
yeah wonder why
it is shameful and authoritarian hurting
the weak to appease the strong that's
the american media 2021
having watched the trial no honest
person could fail to admit the obvious
the media were completely wrong about
kyle rittenhouse they slandered an
innocent kid but they're not admitting
it
there is at least one exception though
we want to highlight that person tonight
her name is anna kasparian she's a lefty
she's on a show called the young turk
she hates this show and most of the time
we disagree with her
but on the question of this trial anna
kasparian was bravely honest and good
for her watch this
look these details matter because if
you're going to make an argument that
you acted in self-defense there needs to
be some proof that there was
an imminent threat now what really
mattered to me was how all of this
unfolded what was the thing that sparked
it what started all of it and initially
i was under the assumption that
rittenhouse was the person who was
chasing after joseph rosenbaum that that
that's how it started but i was wrong
about that okay so i want to correct the
record i was in fact wrong about that
wow you don't see that too often but
it's not hard by the way
tell the truth let reality be your guide
it feels good that's what decent people
do
there are too few of them hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else